on
en
[Musique]
à
nous sommes nous je ne reconnais pas le
on n'en passe pas la salpêtrière comme
la cfdt qui donc pas ça à faire ici ça
ce n'est pas toi qu'il dessine ton père
enfin c'était ton père maintenant c'est
le docteur charles quoi c'est comme ça a
bougé pas amarré
avec l'enchaînement
aux yeux se ferment vous entendez que ma
voix
est-il vrai que vous communiquer avec
les morts mademoiselle tous hectares
calmez vous je me calme si je
nous rions
[Musique]
dans son
passons
ça me forte
ça me va
ça nous et hervé temps
dams et messieurs je vous prie
maintenant d'accueillir celle que vous
attendez tous les dames c'est à vous